ci proveremo nuovi giochi per dirci e
guardate quante diventata grande e
grandissima
cresciuto tantissimo
mi piace per prendere sotto al letto lo
so perché
mi dio oggi proveremo alcuni dei giochi
più popolari che ho trovato su amazon ho
comprato dai giochi vergato che sono i
più votati e ci proveremo con certe e ci
vai dove ti bilità senza giocandolo
sotto ogni gioco daremo un voto da 1 a
10 se volete anche voi di come si scrive
the un voto da 1 a 10 finire mi descrive
te qual è stato il vostro giochi ho
preferito anche noi vi diremo il nostro
preferito basta soprattutto ora stato mi
piace fa perché se quel che vede
raggiunto i 10 mila mi piace però un
altro episodio in cui problemi chi per
gattano anche per kharja vi ricordate
bevuto anche tanti video in cui proviamo
i giochi per cari con bernie non berlino
sta guarendo circe fa pensando ei ma che
sta facendo questa e poi abbiamo
comprato anche un giochino per berlino
anche se berlino distrugge tutti i
giochi li disintegra più comprato un
photokina problemi che gli daremo alla
fine del debito vedrete anche la sua
rete iniziamo subito con il primo giochi
lo rimangia chino che ho comprato è
questa sorta di fiorellino margherita
con con una farfalla finta che sembra
vera tranne per il colore verde berlino
sembra più interessato a questo giochino
va dove c'è dobbiamo attaccare la patata
fa al fiore ecco fatto ho già si muove
in realtà bisogna mettere le batterie
qua vediamo del circeo è interessata è
da berlina non è per me questa è in
ottava mangiando il giochino come il
tempo e berlino è geloso e vanta i
giochini di
minuti
ok
grazie per questo basca il programma
abbiamo subito il giochino a berlino
così sarà più tranquillo e il po di vita
era più tranquillo e non ruberà i giochi
a circe forse gioco per berlino nascosta
dietro alla schiena guardate la sua
faccia conto vedrà il giochino
moltissimo dai tenuto
alla confezione ti dà la pallina
scapolo ecco ora circe sembra geroge
bene però possiamo riprendere a provare
posteggio chiudersi insieme ecco circe
vediamo se le piace questo giochino
sembra di si sta ancora analizzando
no distruggerlo come berlino
pronti a tv
che vuole
che bello sembra un apporto alla vera
sancisce prendi la notizia un po confusa
farfalla
succede
sembra che uccise questo gioco piaciute
di più senza le batterie proviamo a
spegnerlo vediamo se lei è più
interessata a
giocarsi quando effetto bene che voto
diamo questo giochino
lido per mezzo di un se invece
scrivetelo nei commenti passiamo ora
rossi bozouki lo giochino la forma della
zuppa di un gatto sembra super carino
vediamo chi si è già interessata ma è
bellissimo
da sirte
carino
capire a queste sono le varie cose che
si possono attaccare qua alla fine della
stampa quasi è la pallina ha detto
nell'asse la pallina e poi
premendo il momento c'è una molla tira
indietro dopo la bella ci piace un sacco
questo primo piano piano il cielo oppure
velocissimo vediamo
slama circe e felice di questo
tantissimo
proviamo ad attaccare le più merce ad
ora questi giochini con le più mette gli
piacciono tantissimo
proviamo ad attaccare queste diavolo
lo adora tantissimo questo gioco
è appreso non lo molla
io direi che a questo gioco circe da un
10 perché si sta divertendo tantissimo
sirsi si sta divertendo tantissimo solo
con la pallina che era un accessorio dei
giochi diversi di striscia la balena che
per il gioco
abbiamo attaccato due accessori
guardate tutti e due sono molto
interessati ma questo è un gioco per
scazzi perchè altrimenti berlino.lo
distruggerebbe marino subito voi questo
tutto
allora che voto siamo aperti giochino
ccd da un 10 perché stagione attendo da
impazzire
di don 9 perché avrei preferito che la
corda fosse un pochino più lunga è vero
si è più che voto magari qualcosa con il
9 se la cosa fosse stata più lunga 10 st
stiamo al prossimo
attivo giochino questo è un giochino
elettronico sembra tipo un come si
chiamano rumba l'aspirapolvere il robot
ma in realtà è un giochino per gatti
guardate elettronico e dovrebbe far
uscire a ri accessori da uno di questi
buchetti offriamo le vediamo come
funziona ed
eccolo qua è stranissimo veramente un
aspirapolvere robot
comunque basta premere il pulsante casa
guardate
nell'audio mai una di questi buchi che
ci sono tutti attorno
vediamo se circe e interpretata sono tre
modalità lento medio è vero ecco berlino
che arriva a controllare sempre tutte le
stato berlino che ci eccetera ma eccolo
da berlino e questo mi piace tutti e due
velocità in media
sta provando a prenderlo ma non capisce
perché non esce da lì ecco berlino da
una mano circe e tutti e due stanno
provando a prenderlo ma non ci riesce
[Risate]
però distruggetelo berlino sta provando
a distruggerlo con le tappe dai di circe
questo per dire che con merlino che sto
aspettando che
parli dai kiss e puoi farcela prenderlo
forse l'ho dobbiamo mettere più veloce
marlino sta aiutando gir.c a prenderlo
questo gioco è diventato un lavoro di
squadra per
la facciamo più veloce ok modalità
veloce chi dei due riuscirà a prendere i
giorni con le più
berlino il distruttore
berlioz volesse macchiarlo dai merlino
no se giocare indiretti lascia molto
chiare circa ecco fatto circe finalmente
può giocare in pace senza che il
fratello maggiore gli rubi giocattoli
dai pregiudizi prima che carino ha
pensato ei ma prima il giochino è uscito
da qua perché ora esce dalla bechis e
premium
in questo gioco sembra che le piaccia
molto anche se non corre tantissimo come
quell'altro proposti sembra che adesso
nando e pensando riuscirò a prenderlo
devo pensare a dove uscirà giochino
per vi state chiedendo perché circe cade
ogni tanto o in campo non cammina molto
bene ne ho parlato nel video in quando
lo abbiamo adottato se non l'avete visto
andate a vederlo poi purtroppo però
l'abbiamo portata da due mete riina lì
per capire se si poteva risolvere il
problema ma purtroppo non è una cosa che
si può risolvere perché dovrebbe essere
una cosa neurologica cioè a livello del
certo eletto lì comunque felicissime
campigli stima noi la riempiamo di
attenzione le vogliamo calcio si può
bene quindi lei non sta nemmeno di avere
questo problema solo che ogni tanto in
campo e cade carlino fratello maggiore
deve rubare i giochi alla sorella
chi se lo prende lo produce memoria di
lui lavora aiutare a tre cerchi
allora che a voto diamo a questo gioco
tears e che voto dai a questo gioco mi
sembra che a certi le piaccia molto
ridere in un 9 e mezzo
sì anch'io sono d'accordo con questo
però dai 19 e voi che voto date scrive
non è come il titolo questo è l'ultimo
giochino ed ecco che arriva subito merli
laboratorio che voi tutto per lui che
cosa è questo giochino è una sorta di
circuito vedete il circuito
che si può costruire ma si possono anche
cambiare le forme e dentro ci vanno le
palline quindi il gatto gioca con la
staffetta a spingere le palline nel
situare
bellissimo apriamo noi vediamo come
ecco tu stai 2 che arrivano tutti e due
e controllare e qua abbiamo i vari
pendini circuito da montare
cs sta già procedendo
vero faccia una pallina
attenzione sta già impazzando circe
perfetto anche merlino ovviamente che
deve prendere tutta oltre palline
archimede di cui già in arrivo vuole
aiutare
a berlino vuole costruire il circuito
capitolo gintama con i denti
bravo ok mica costruire il nostro
circuito
the brat i suoi giochini tipo
che costruisce i circuiti per le
macchinine accetta lo costruiamo insieme
a vitale costruito il percorso perché
lui adora
le macchinine turco sta controllando sta
osservando i lavori vediamo se approva
il nostro percorso delle fortissima
falli e
possiamo fare varie forme in questo
percorso possiamo cambiarlo poi quindi
se ci si abitua al percorso e si annoiò
possiamo poi
creare un nuovo percorso con un'altra
forma è molto facile da montare basta
mettere questo pezzo qua sopra che fare
giocando con il percorso anche se non lo
abbiamo ancora finito
per interessata completato circuito
completa 13 poi c'è questo mito vitale
vediamo se ci piace
wow
prova a prendere la pallina ma
ovviamente
c'è carino ovest a me piace tanto mi sa
dov'è andata non lo vedo più sta qui
vediamo se spinge anche lei la pallina
con le zampe
anche le
spinge
[Risate]
sembra che tutti e divertendo molto
circe le piace questo giochino e non è
lina pali race se non lo sono smonta
non è un limite
se non si è accorta che la pallina
invita chi si viene marlino distruggerlo
ecco ora proverò io a costruire un
percorso il cambio forma vediamo se
accise piace più il mio percorso quello
di vita ne prendiamo tutti i pezzi nardò
guardate il circuito che ho costruito
fatto un circuito fondo
crediamo sia diverso in testa
sembra
essere più rotondo
ha girato intorno per un po
vedete ogni tanto cade pure
mi piace il corpo quindi dire che lo
lasciamo rotonda forse perché provare
altre emma e stefano zampini eccole qua
e addirittura messa all'interno
[Applauso]
cliccare mi piace troppo rotondo
prediletti non riesce a capire dove
si è mangiato un maso corto e
carlo non pronto trova ho trovate qui e
qui la presa per onde troppo esame
l'avanzo ecco è riuscita a farla fallire
incredibile
che caino che
ho
preso è perché
è troppo carina che si è sdraiata dentro
al cerchio aggiunto casa e allora io a
questo gioco ti do un bel 10 perché
stato stile divertente da montagna che
si possono fare altre forme e anche che
circe lo aldo ragni 9 10 quindi questo è
il mio gioco preferito in assoluto per
scoprire quale gioco preferito di circe
avremo la prova finale e cioè metteremo
tutti i giochi in fila eh vedremo da
palle basse circe pronti via allora
posizioniamo tutti i giochi per primo
poi poi la farfalla il resto che
dobbiamo accettarlo e poi
questa vediamo lo sceglie ci sembra che
sia più interessata al don pensa che mi
piace tantissimo il salto
proviamo però ad azionare anche questo
la farfalla e poi
la pallina se indoviniamo salvo tutto
[Applauso]
allontaniamo lì un po
sembra che la farfalla non le piaccia
quando
si forse è meglio spegnerla tait il
quale sei di e chiuderò è indecisa forse
sta scegliendo la farfalla eppure prima
non le piaceva molto vediamo quello con
cui gioca di più ha detto è incredibile
quello che sembrava che non le piazzette
all'inizio
adesso le piace tantissimo e cioè la
farfalla
ma come ci segnala farfalla in tutto che
non ti piaceva prima che essa ha
cambiato idea pensando invece dal
campanellino nella zampa
questi segni e quello ha chiesto
come suo gioco preferito la zampetta
anzi se adesso
arriveranno a nudo un altro giochino
vediamo cosa una farfalla
ho l'impressione che a cir ci è piaciuto
prime stagioni ovvero
bechis e subito preferito no è tornato
alla non appena la mia amicizia e
sceglie la zampetta
è stato ben mi piace e ora vi lasciamo
fa quattro punte di vento e poi cliccare
per vedere inoltre altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite buona visione
ciao